- Two.
Three. Oh, hey.
What's up, guys?
- Are you filming?
Is it cool if we're in here?
- It's actually very cool
that you're in here.
I'm super-pumped.
This director,
he's, like, shooting
a documentary on me right now.
It's, like,
30 for 30 style, like--
- All this
for Comedy Central?
- [whispering]
I honestly don't know
what it's for.
I have no idea!
He says he, like,
knows me from my hometown.
It's like a fluff piece,
I think.
Just pretend like
they're not even here.
- Perfect, man.
We weren't even here
to work out anyway,
you know.
We're just hoping to see
some girls with some butts
that would drive us nuts.
- Oh, you dirty dogs.
- Look, it's crazy.
Look at this!
Look, look, he's nuts.
- Oh, break it down!
- He's driven nuts.
- Oh-ho-ho. You nasty thing.
- Okay, sorry to interrupt
whatever this is.
We need to keep going.
- I'm sorry, guys.
Yeah, all right.
I'll--I'll catch up
with you later.
I hope you're driven nuts...
- My man.
- By big old butts.
- Yeah, what I want to do--
- I have, like, a little pimple
right there.
If we could Photoshop
that out.
- It's not rolling.
- Okay, yeah.
- So what we want
to do is sort of
get your comedic proc--
I want to film you
sort of doing
what you'd normally do
when you're writing comedy.
- My process
when I write comedy.
[singsong]
I'm writing jokes! Comedy--
[dramatic music]
- Genius or idiot?
- Okay, Adam, that's a cut.
That was really good, man.
- Did you get it?
Hey, did you get it?
It was funny 'cause I was
writing under a waterfall.
- This is gonna be easier
than I expected.
[chuckles]
- Yeah, I can't hear you
'cause
I'm under a waterfall.
[theme music plays]